on est effectivement dans une tendance
longue d'amélioration du pouvoir d'achat
est effectivement cet exemple de la
voiture est intéressant aussi puisque
aujourd'hui on paye plus de deux fois
moins cher une voiture qui calme de bien
meilleure qualité la deux chevaux des
années soixante dix vous souvenez c'est
le toit en toile c'est la direction un
peu dur même très dur sur toile et ces
gens soient le pas de ceinture de
sécurité un seul rétroviseurs à gauche
comme dans toutes les voitures à
l'époque à moteur qui est voilà qui
était ce qu'il était donc donc on est
une voiture assez légères d'ailleurs les
voitures sont deux fois plus lourde
aujourd'hui parce qu'elles sont deux
fois plus équipés et donc il ya vous
avez aujourd'hui un airbag un autoradio
évidemment enfin même même système de
sont embarqués vous avez évidemment de
votre viseur vous avez toutes les
sécurités direction assistée donc on est
dans une qualité qui s'est largement
amélioré et malgré ça le coup
effectivement et de formateur est
d'ailleurs le seul aujourd'hui la
plupart des français ont une voiture au
moins une voiture ce qui n'est pas du
tout le cas d'insomnie ce dont on a
effectivement se gagnent foire d'achat
ce qui n'empêche pas effectivement ce
que les et christophe ramaux c'est la
logique de de se comparer dans une
relativement à sa propre époque et donc
le fait qu'il ya effectivement des
détentions et des douleurs quand
effectivement quand je parle de la crise
de l'abondance on parle bien de crise
qui sont bien réels
[Musique]